what is happening everybody welcome to
the very first episode I didn't even
play any music did I
I didn't play music now and it doesn't
matter you wanna sing something
can you sing no the very first episode
of fairly normal with Josh wolf my guest
today the very first guest is the
creator of shows such as my name is
Errol and raising hope and yes dear and
not we're the Millers because we're the
Millers let's just say it's we're the
Millers because the Millers got
cancelled fairly we're the Millers is a
movie that people seem to really like I
really did like it how many people how
many people called your show we're the
Millers lots of people lots of people
and I would get credit for in fact I saw
I was on oh my great Garcia everybody
Greg Garcia
go ahead going yeah I I saw on the
street in New York someone was selling
scripts and it was we're the Millers and
I was credited as the writer not
terrible I thought that was great yeah
yeah would you did you ever tell him
when people did you ever some when
someone said for your the we're the
Millers you were like yeah that's right
I just say thanks yeah yeah and then
they asked me what Jennifer Aniston was
like and I'm like she kind of a bit I
love that you know I when people like
sometime if you get credit for something
that's not your as I'm with you I don't
correct people it but I also don't
correct people if someone says to me my
brother's this kind of [ __ ] like
around Christmastime if someone goes
Merry Christmas he's the [ __ ] who
goes I'm Jewish
oh yeah what's the point that's the
point just let that roll yeah now I've
known you for a long time yeah it's been
a while and for okay so I think we're
almost done this is it right this is the
wrap this is just so you know this is
the wrap I met Greg okay so a long time
ago when this was before had you had you
had a show in the area um I believe so
yeah I'd hide I'll show I had had the
ironically named built to last on the
air which lasted three episodes so yeah
I had had one show on the air when I met
you and we the the studio that we were
both working with set us up to write
the Joshua yabai exactly yeah yeah we
were gonna do a sitcom basically about
your life but it was decided that I was
not experienced enough to do it on my
own so we were given ace an executive
producer who was supervising me as a
writer yes you won't say his name so I
will his name was Danny Jacobson yeah it
was a mess I tell stories about that
because listen Greg was I guess at that
time in your early stages of your career
yes yeah very early okay and Danny had
written mad about life you John Roseanne
okay long career yes he also was a big
fan of sweatpants with no underwear
loved it he was such a huge fan every
meeting was just we'd sweatpants no
underwear and he was the pioneer of the
crock he really was yeah might not have
been the crock but it was a crab's a
crock lifestyle yeah very much do you
know when I used to after listening and
Greg wrote of what ended up being the
best script the best version but Danny
asked the studio to get rid of you yeah
I believe so he was threatened by your
script I do know and I do remember
turning into the script to him and he
said he's gonna look at it and then a
week later it showed up on my doorstep
and it was also delivered to the network
and it had both our names on it as
writer yeah his and then mine and it was
nothing like the script that I had
written no it was a brand-new script
there's a brand new his script and
here's hey by the way I want you to know
what his writing process was his writing
process I went to his house he invited a
writer over who he would not let me
address by name he said you have to call
him clack e while he's here so he would
say clack e take this down yeah but
before we could write a joke he would
take some weed out and he would have
this you know the the screen drop from
the ceiling
and we would watch like two hours of The
Honeymooners and then he would be like
now I'm ready to write I'm like my god
with your [ __ ] balls I mean it was it
was pretty pretty terrible that was a
mess I went over there one time and he
had come out of the bath
which he had stunk up and we had I had
my writers assistant with me and the
right assistant needed to use the
bathroom but he didn't want to go in
there because it stunk and so Danny lit
up a joint and then blew a bunch of
smoke in there I mean my writer sister
doesn't smoke weed or do any drugs
looked at me with like extreme terror in
the eyes and then went into the
smoke-filled bathroom well so basically
but I think that's a that's a fallacy
whenever you put a smell over it's like
when you spray potpourri just smells
like I'm [ __ ] on the potpourri like no I
don't think it helped yeah nothing
covers up the smell of [ __ ] no he just
got a little high and had to smell Danny
that was the end result yeah that's his
first chapter of his new book that yeah
all right a couple people just let you
know this and we talked a little bit
about this you are one of three I would
say TV writers where if I say their name
people like oh I [ __ ] love that guy
like you have some notoriety like a star
like a celebrity you would not agree
with that no I wouldn't I mean but I do
I appreciate that I appreciate that
there's people out there that kind of
know my brand and the shows that they
have liked because I was like to say
I've created some shows you've liked and
some you haven't cared for that's how I
describe myself let me ask you a
question
how would you describe your brand
because I have a question about about
your shows but how would you describe
your brand I would say my brand if I
wanted to brand myself I would say
quirky with heart that's where I feel
like I do my best work which I would say
my name is Earl and raising hope fit
that category and I've done some failed
pilots that fit that category not to
take anything away from the other shows
that I've done which may not fall into
that as much but I'd like to think that
that is more my brand and you know and
when you do different shows a lot of
times you do different shows because of
where it's gonna be on the network it's
show business at the end of the day
right so if you're gonna do things for a
particular network at a particular time
for a particular time slot you're trying
to get you're gonna write a different
show than you would write if you just
sit down and go I'm just gonna write a
script and try to sell it but you're
here's the thing man which is it by the
way and you've had me on a couple of
your shows
and I noticed that you always named my
character Josh like you don't think I'm
smart enough to figure out somebody
else's name or are you but here it
strikes me funny most shows either
appeal to the middle of the country or
the coasts yes sure okay
your shows the characters on your shows
appeal to the middle of the country
they're very identifiable people a lot
of the jokes appeal to the coast like it
so that's the crazy combination I feel
like that you have that a lot of people
Earl was a very smart show yeah and then
we had really good writers who wrote
very smart jokes and I think yeah that's
a very good combination to have I mean
you know if you can get everybody to
relate to it and that's when you're
gonna hit on all cylinders and and do
well well one is about see I guess I
know where'd you grow up Arlington
Virginia okay and so where there's some
is Arlington's on that border of what we
could be the north or we could be yeah I
mean Arlington's right outside DC so
like I grew up in a pretty suburban
middle-class neighborhood however I have
people in my family who are either have
spent time in jail who live a little
further out that are more blue-collar I
had a friend in high school a guy that's
a fellow writer now Michael Mike penny
who lived in a trailer park for a while
and I can go over there and visit so I
had a lot of access to different parts
of life yeah which were very interesting
to me but it's so is that fit is that
how you got like those Earle characters
is you those go back to where you grew
up I think somewhat yeah I mean
certainly they're loosely based on you
know I've had people in my life who went
through a a many times and tried to turn
their life around many times and always
would be doing the making amends part of
it and and then ultimately screw up and
and and and get back to where they were
so that was certainly part of Erle you
know I had one of my uncle's was married
to a woman named joy and
I don't know I know maybe I just took
the name from that and then put in my
head what I thought that she actually
was because I don't have real good
memories of her as I'm saying this I'm
realizing I don't want her to she knows
that no don't worry she's not that you
know that's uh okay so Earl and somebody
asked me to ask you this uh I could I
had so many people ask questions online
so I'm gonna try to get all of them so
Earl right yeah when it gets canceled
yeah a shock to you yeah really I mean
we had a we did a cliffhanger for the
season four finale and it was still
getting ratings right wasn't it it was
still doing pretty good it wasn't at its
height what happened with Earl was it
just exploded at the beginning they put
a ton of money into promoting it it was
like their big show it actually really
helped the office which wasn't doing
very well right start to get a better
off incidence it did really well for
them and then they moved it and that's
always trouble
at least it's usually trouble and they
told me don't worry we're still gonna
support it whatever they gonna move it
I've any time I've had a show get moved
that's when it starts going downhill and
so he got moved and then slowly it
started to lose the ratings and it
settled into you know what ultimately
was a normal show for them it didn't
wasn't at its height anymore but I was a
little concerned you know it was a
fourth season I was like I wonder are
they gonna keep going it and I doing it
and I asked NBC I said I'm think about
doing a cliffhanger ending are we safe
and they're like yeah you're you're safe
no problem
and then yeah then we got cancelled it's
the first time that I had it because you
have a pretty good here's what I love
about you do you have a pretty good
grasp on reality
you're the most humble ultra successful
person that I know like you are a truly
humble dude if someone tells you you're
funny there's a part of you that still
doesn't believe it no I don't believe it
which is [ __ ] insane because look and
I told you this when I asked you to come
on on do the panel on my show you were
like why I'm not a comic I don't want to
embarrass you I'm like dude your top
five funny people like your jokes are
okay so but it's the first like I think
it was the first time I had talked
to you a little bit where you seemed a
little mad that you were a symbol little
you were like well [ __ ] ya you see but
it was the first time I had seen a
little anger from that no I was a little
I was bummed out about the whole thing
and you know I remember that the press
called me and they said like how do you
feel and I said because NBC doesn't
wasn't doing all the time and I said
well it's hard to get upset about being
thrown off of the Titanic and their lady
from the LA Times is like oh my god I
wish you would let me print that and I
was like why wouldn't I
seems like the right thing to do which I
think they got pretty upset about I
remember that but here's another thing
dude what is the best about you and
ultimately what I'm learning about
successful people you have to have
especially in this town at least a
little bit of [ __ ] you you have to have
a little bit of that I think it helps I
mean it's a risk to have that you know
and I think you have to couple that with
like you know being nice to people yeah
and and being willing to collaborate and
stuff like that but yeah at the end of
the day I've done shows where I've done
everything they want me to do and they
don't get on or stay on and you don't
get rewarded for that and then like when
we did My Name Is Earl Jason Lee and
Mark Buckland and I sat down before we
did the pilot we were like we're gonna
do the show we want to do and screw them
if they don't put it on and we lucked
out and they put it on but I think you
to be creative you should you should do
what you want to do well I don't think
that's looking out you know one thing
that I did learn and I've learned from
you and also learn from other people
that I've worked with like channels
which is you have to make what you're
making like nobody's watching it yeah
make it for you like what you think is
funny and then hopefully people because
if you start making it for other people
it's not gonna know and that's what I've
always done is I try to do shows that I
would watch and that I haven't always
been able to do that for the most part
that's what I try to do and then you
just hope that you're in sync with the
audience out there or at least a portion
of the audience that has the same
sensibilities as you have how much is a
successful show and I know writing
obviously important is the chemistry of
the people on the screen oh it's huge I
mean I think when it comes down to
sitcoms what really works at the end of
the day is characters that people want
to watch on TV and humor and then yeah
I'm a big slave to story I want great
stories and interesting stories but for
the most part I don't know how much the
audience cares on a weekly basis about
stories I think you know the cast and
the comedy are the key components there
I remember when we were doing Earl and
the office was on at the same time as I
said my dad used to call me all the time
after the show and tell me what he
thought of the show and he'd always say
he thought it was a funny episode and
then sometimes he'd talk about the
office too and one time I watched the
office and there was no story
there was just it was weird it was like
it was just the episode where they were
doing this I don't know this party and
it was just not much of a story and then
we had this really intricate story and I
thought god I'm killing myself on these
stories with twists and turns and there
was no story there my dad called me goes
but did you see the office tonight
that was awesome and I said but what was
the story tell me what the story was he
goes I don't know she that got fall off
the plane hilarious can I tell you
something which is funny because I
remember something you told me when you
had me write on yes here for a little
bit and you also co-created right yes
the area yes okay one of the things I
remember asking you why I didn't mean it
in a why is this show still in the air
yeah but it was the question is what do
you think and you were like because
there's what you said people like the
characters I guarantee them to laugh out
loud moments a show story simple you
said simple story I guarantee they're
gonna laugh twice out loud and they like
the characters and that's what that's
enough yeah I think it is and then also
once you gain a little moment in
physical comedy you told me people love
physical comment they love it they love
fart jokes in physical comments why not
give them a little bit of that yeah I
think you know and I try to spice it up
in my shows where it's like look you if
you don't like physical comedy then
there's gonna be some clever you know
thoughtful jokes in there but if you
like physical comedy there's gonna be
some of that too and just try to like
sparse it out you know get it out this
probably the wrong word sparse sparked
no you wouldn't sparse something out
sparse would be like there isn't a lot
of something right Shh you're asking
that you're asking vocabulary words so
the guy who's got eight
I think bring cool
maybe you sprinkle it no doesn't sparse
play for the Seahawks is in your
receiver yes I have him yeah I need him
to go off where is there any as far as
casting goes yeah can you think of a
time for you where you either we're like
I didn't want that guy and I looked out
or do you like can you ever because how
much of the casting ends up in your lap
as opposed to the network because I've
you've told me off script off air about
some people you fought for that you
didn't get but is there anybody were you
like that was a surprise to me what a
[ __ ] great surprise that was I'm
trying to think I mean I don't know if
there was any great surprises because
usually I mean I have fought for people
in the past and then and lost
unfortunately but I can't think of
anybody that was really jammed down my
throat you know where I was like no no
no no like everybody usually if they
don't want somebody I want usually we
can find somebody that we agree on right
so I don't know if I've had any shocking
things like that you find Ethan suplex
well Ethan was you know I'll tell that
first by saying how I found Jason which
was interesting because he I want him to
do him to read the script and he didn't
want to read it he didn't want to do TV
and then ultimately we got him to read
it and he came in for a meeting and we
had a great meeting it was me and him in
the director and we left that meeting
thinking oh he's gonna he's gonna do it
you know and he said he's gonna do it so
they try to make his deal all week and
then it was like Friday night and they
told me go to bed we just got to figure
out the deal it's gonna be fine
woke up Saturday morning they said he's
out he doesn't want to do it he's not
gonna do TV who'd you have did you have
a second choice no I had met with
everybody under the Sun I mean everybody
from like Stephen Baldwin to Chris Penn
to Luke pare everybody in the world was
coming in to read for this thing we'd
we'd been like at it for two months I
thought we'd finally had cracked the
code and so I was bummed out and then I
was talking to his manager gay Ribisi
who's Giovanni Ribisi 'he's mother and
she said I don't know what to tell you
I'm bummed out so the next morning I
woke up and I took my son who was five
at the time to
Santa Monica Art Festival and I received
Giovanni Ribisi and I'm like well that's
weird so I'm like I didn't want to
bother him but I thought they're so
weird I was telling his mother and I
said hey it's nice to it's nice to meet
you I'm a fan but also I was talked to
your mother yesterday and he goes oh my
mother's right here you should say hi so
I say hi to her and then she said oh
this is my daughter and this is her
husband Beck and I'm like oh hello back
enough to be quite quite an afternoon at
the biggie and I said well I'm here with
my son she goes Jason was gonna come
with us but he's so messed up in his
head about this TV thing and not doing
it and he didn't come it's okay then I
went with my son to go see our Cole play
basketball in a show league what in a
show business league he specifically
requested to see her play basketball
no because Jaleel and I are friends and
I knew he was playing in this league so
I went down there to watch him cuz I
knew I was gonna be in Santa Monica and
then I get a call and it's gay Ribisi
and she says I just talked to Jason he
can't believe you were at the art thing
he thinks it's fate and he'll do the
show that was the reason he decided to
do the show so I said to her I said he
should call me tomorrow cuz I don't want
him to do this show cuz I went to the
art that seems like a bad idea because
it seems like he could be like oh I went
into 7-eleven instead of the kwik-e-mart
I'm not doing the show yeah exactly yeah
so we we met and then it made sense he
was just like no no he goes that got me
thinking about it but he said listen I
want to do all different things as an
actor and I want to do TV and if I'm
gonna do TV I love this and so let's do
this so then so he was on board and then
did you already have Jamie at that point
we had nobody it was like you got to get
Earl before you get the rest of the cast
so that was it so then I don't know what
at what point we got Jamie I mean she
just came into my office and started
reading it it was like forget it
everybody else go home by the way she
was so good in that like so good in that
ridiculous and then Ethan was friends
with Jason they had known each other
since they were 14 so he came in he
didn't really want to audition because
he just says it makes him nervous and
he's not great audition we end up
putting him on tape and then we show the
to the network and he got the part but
that's the thing like look chemistry of
the cast together
look the obviously the words are super
important but if the people on the
screen don't have chemistry while
they're doing it you're [ __ ] no and
that was such a bonus I mean here's two
guys that like they're at craft service
and they're messing with each other and
throwing food at each other and they've
known each other till they're 14 and
then they're on screen playing brothers
and doing the same thing and it just
comes so naturally to them I mean it's I
would imagine it's like hiring a couple
to play an actual couple on TV yeah
because look I always go back to there
have been the ton of scripts that I've
read I'm like this is [ __ ] funny and
then you see it on the screen you're
like that is not funny at all yeah and
to me it just has to do with the two
people saying it to each other no
question and a lot of times those
characters come in and they do stuff
that you wouldn't expect in your head
and it's so much better than even what
you thought I mean what do you mean I'm
saying like you have a you have a way
you wrote a joke and you're like you
know in your head how that's supposed to
sound because that's why you put it on
paper and then someone says it
differently and a lot of times you're
like holy [ __ ] that's that's that's
amazing I didn't know you were gonna say
it like that and it's like is like an
almost a different meaning to it how
much play do you give into this does it
depend on the actor how much play do you
give the actor with your script do you
go say it for me one time the way I
wrote it and then you can say it one
time the way you want yeah I mean
usually there's an understanding that we
work really hard on the scripts and we
like to hear the words whoo the way we
wrote them and for the most part I've
always had a very great relationship
with the actors and they understand that
and they like they like the words now
sometimes they'll come to me before the
scene and go this seems weird and and
I'm like yeah that is weird and I can
either convince them why it's supposed
to be like that or I see their point and
we change it or if we don't see eye to
eye yeah I'll say okay listen I do it
this way and then let's do it your way
and they know at least if they don't
know right off the bat they know after
doing that a few times that if I get to
editing in their ways better then we put
their way in so no we go for you know I
don't care I you know the editors a huge
resource for me because I say to the
editor put what you think is best in
so whenever I get my first cut I already
know what they thought and so then will
sometimes sit in the room and I'll say
okay well show me the other ones and
we'll have a discussion and no I don't
at the end of the day it's just
whatever's the best thing on the screen
I don't care
dude you're you're Emmy speech was epic
that was fun
anybody who's listening this who has not
heard your Emmy speech hears it's
another reason why look in a town where
people take themselves entirely too
seriously you may not take yourself
seriously enough like you have a fun
night you know someone was asked me the
other day what am I like I had this
meeting with this comedian funny guy any
and he was like his name's funny guy his
name's funny guy great name for a comic
I mean you know it's just right there on
maybe a little to all the knows I'm just
gonna say funny guy maybe a little too
on-the-nose he delivers Josh so he was
asking me like what was the what what am
I most proud of or something and I go
that speech was the best young ever
because I'm not usually in front of the
camera so I write things and other
people get laughs and and even so much
like I love like traveling with Jason
when we were doing my name is ro and
just being in airports and stuff and you
see like people going nuts I don't get
that kind of feedback and that's like
really cool so that was the first time
where I was in front of an audience on
TV and in front of all my peers and I
knew I was like if I win this thing I
think I got a pretty good speech like I
think this would be good and when I
started getting laughs I get like a
little smirk on my face yeah and I'm
like this is nice I mean I see why you
guys do it this was very cool and then
the coolest part is I walked offstage
and Conan O'Brien who was hosting was
standing there and he goes how the [ __ ]
am I supposed to follow that ha ha and
he said you're not it's over for you
know that was that was a lot of fun that
was a lot of fun but don't you have fun
you do you've done you've been on your
own shows and you have Wilfred and a
couple of K yeah yeah yeah it's not like
you don't like doing it no no I like fun
coming on my show I had a great time
coming on your show that was a lot of
getting a good feedback I
people people like that it was fun III
my wife gave me a lot of crap about my
beard listen your beard and anybody
saying at that point what article is
that is that deadline Oh deadline did a
story on me today and they had a picture
and I didn't like it so I sent him a
picture of me that I've made him put in
it's ridiculous he looks like a homeless
dude who talks about helicopters oh did
you see that like you would be twiddling
your thumbs a lot like I looked at that
picture like you sent me the articles
like dude this is like I know but that's
the part like you don't take yourself
seriously no what's the point you gotta
have fun you have a good time are you by
but there's no like you're you
understand your perspective look what I
don't know how to talk you were you
created hope yeah and I was on your set
when you were running it and I was on
your set that set when you weren't yeah
when you're on a set and I've always and
I kind of took this from you when I was
on mine it's all trickle-down yeah the
attitude I lose all trickle-down
absolutely but I watched you talk to
people like actors and the reason I
asked you about the line is that your
firm but giving it's that fair yeah I
mean look I'm very specific about what I
want I'm very controlling I I you know
and that's no secret to anybody that
I've ever worked with I have a vision
but also will listen to all the ideas
but if I if everyone's against me and I
feel like it needs to be a certain way
that's the way we're gonna do it and you
know it's just cuz I have to trust
myself and I want to go to bed at night
knowing that I did it the way I thought
it should be either you know sink or
swim and I think part of running a show
also is part of it is you're hosting a
party I mean you're you're people are
looking to you to set the tone to how to
behave you know how to treat other
people you know if you come in there and
I've noticed if I come in there and I'm
like stressed out and I'm worried about
something that's the way kind of people
act and you come in there and you're
laughing and making jokes and like on
Earl when I would dress up as Wilfred
and I would refuse to get that break
character and I would wear the wig and
the mustache it's so good and I would
just go in and just I would n plus it
was a great release for me from
stress run the show I wouldn't I would
refuse to break character and Wilfred
would come down and he would [ __ ] with
people you explain to people what it was
like so Wilfred was I just decided I was
gonna put myself on the show and I would
wear a wig and I'm in a mustache I think
I played Tim stacks agent yes and and
Wilfred would just come in and and he's
you know he bye all right guys car how
y'all doing man this is the best goddamn
crew in the world man I love coming here
and and and people would just have fun
with it one day I was working I was
directing an episode as Wilfred no I was
directing as as myself other Wilfred
should've director by just directing by
myself and Geraldo Rivera was in the
episode my you had some great guest
stars on that show oh we had so many
great guest stars we were so lucky that
people wanted to do the show and it was
fun and we're doing this one bizarre
episode in Geraldo Rivera was like in
the episode and I told him I knew I had
a scene with Wilfred coming up next and
I said listen there's a guy coming in
who's gonna direct because I got a run
out for an hour for a meeting and he
goes okay so then I went to the makeup
trailer and I got in Wilfred stuff and I
come out and Geraldo's at craft service
and I yell over and I'm like Geraldo hey
man hey we're gonna sing together coming
up buddy can't wait and he kind of just
waves to me like what the [ __ ] and so we
sit down and I sit down across from him
in the scene at a table and he goes how
you doing and I go give me second
Geraldo give me a second here man
I lost a fish this morning and I'm a
little upset and he goes okay he goes
I'm sorry was it a was it a koi and I go
[ __ ] koi man I'm what am i Geraldo
Rivera was a goddamn goldfish I can't
afford a goddamn koi man just give me a
second all right
so he says okay fine and I kept kind of
messing with him and then I left and I
came back and directed the rest of the
episode and he I knew never knew did he
ever mention Wilford to you the next
morning he came up to me at craft
service and he had been in the makeup
trailer telling them about the weird guy
that he had to do a scene with and they
told him so he claims up comes up to me
at craft service next more he goes you
son of a [ __ ] huh yes that I mean you
listen the guest stars you had on that
show were amazing but who was the dude
that's saying did he write on your staff
and you only had him on the show and he
would sing oh dang casino yeah yeah dang
casino was great he was he was you
populated your shows with bizarre
[ __ ] people the daytime hooker is my
favorite character out of any tale dick
he's so amazing yeah we had a lot of fun
in fact it was funny because we had this
one we had like the one of the first
episodes in the first batch we had this
guy who was like he had no he had one
arm and no legs and he had these like
metal legs and we did a thing where he
dated the one-legged girl we had on the
show and he like chased Earl down the
road remember that yeah in the metal
things with the metal things and like
one of my favorite scenes ever he had
gotten hit by a train and that's what
happened to him and the director at one
point I told director I said he's not
coming out fast enough tell him to come
out faster that's me I want a guy with
no legs to come out faster because it'll
be funnier and the director went up and
said you got to come out like a freight
train you know what I'm talking about
and the guys like yeah I think the
director came back and he told the guy
who lost his legs to a train to come out
like a train so where to go it was
fantastic so yeah so so the casino was
that Dan casino was a production
assistant who would always like sing
prints to us and stuff in the office and
then yeah you just sitting around late
at night you're like put Dan in the
thing and they're like then they said
the Wardrobe came said what do you want
dan casino to wear in the show and I
said I want him to wear a white t-shirt
that says with black letters Dan casino
that is what he wants yeah yeah I was
wondering why yeah that'd do it listen
uh the Dan casino like and I was on an
episode where he and all you did was
have him sing yeah yeah he would sing
yeah he would sing a lot yessing a lot
but music was a big part of Erle they
gave us a great music budget I mean
right off the bat they decided that they
were gonna like give us a real healthy
music budget and they let us really just
like write episodes and kind of drive to
songs like I would have songs in mind
I'm be like I know I want Earl doing X
under this song let's get to that point
you know and it was powerful it was good
you know music is you know if you can
throw a Rolling Stone song into the end
of an episode you know it's really
really you know
dramatic alright somebody wanted me to
ask you any chance you ever do an Earl
movie yeah I've gotten asked that a few
times you know 20th Century Fox owns
Earl I would I would certainly be up for
it it would be a lot of fun the process
of running around and trying to sell a
movie seems a little different
it's different it's uh it's
time-consuming and I'm usually doing
stuff I'd be open to it but I think what
also will people in this outside of the
town don't know and correct me if I'm
wrong if you walk into a room to sell a
TV show you have a ton of cash eh if you
walk into a room to sell a movie it
doesn't translate no not so much your
baby literally the crazy thing is you
would think this guy with that track
record could walk into it and go he can
write but the movie people don't give a
[ __ ] about what the TV people are
writing no and also it comes down to you
know it's it's there's not a lot of
unknowns they know what it is and then
they have to do the numbers and see is
this going to translate into money for
us you know they made a Man From UNCLE
that was from the [ __ ] 20s I think
they could figure it out they make money
with that I don't know I think I think
it would be a ton of fun and and a lot
of fun to write but I'm kind of in the
position where somebody needs to just
knock on my door and go hey you want to
do this and then I'd be like yeah let's
do it
and I got one more question for you then
we're gonna move on somebody who also
wanted me to ask you out of the people
on the cast
yeah and I'm see if I can translate this
question was there anybody who
consistently delivered lines that you
didn't think were gonna be funny in a
funny way do you know anywhere that
wasn't written funny but you were the
one they said it they were like oh
that's for that I don't know that that
was it's supposed to be funny
you know I would say and let me just
preface this by saying that cast was
amazed amazing they always delivered
every single one of them but for that
specific question I would probably say
Ethan simply because and by the way I
don't really as I'm sitting right here
know if it's Ethan so plea or Ethan sup
Lee and he's told me a million
I'm sooo play I know so who knows I help
always set it wrong I introduced him at
a table read not long ago I think I got
it wrong again there's something wrong
with my brain but I was a boy not I
don't know it maybe were you Aaron what
were you the Wikipedia please everything
on Wikipedia is true cuz they said how
would you know on Wikipedia cuz of the
lines over something I think phonetic
you know one of those two dots the oom
clot that the new malotte
yeah whom snot what is it I don't know
it's the two dots buddy okay from it's
like in every single Slayer song there's
those yeah that's right yeah okay all
right so I would say Ethan because Ethan
would always you know he would end up
taking like a different angle at things
sometimes and surprise you more than
other people where other people would
just really deliver the line perfectly
and you know
not unlike Garret Dillahunt on raising
Hope where you thought you wrote a
straight line and you did not write a
straight line but that leads me
perfectly into the next question if
somebody asks because look all I knew
from Garret Dillahunt was the Jesse
James movie where I was like this dude
is an amazing act insane an amazing
actor yeah how do you think to call him
in for a con I don't even think to call
him in and the truth is he did comedy
before he did the crazier stuff he was
on he's a true he was on nor McDonald's
for cameras it come and he was uh I
think it was so he wasn't on your list
of people to call in I didn't I had
watched Deadwood yeah I was a fan but I
didn't know his name and so and then
he's such a chameleon he comes in yeah -
he came in an audition I think he might
have been in New York and he went on
tape and I watched it and I was like
this dude's amazing like he's the guy
there's no question about it and then
later I had to like look and go oh [ __ ]
that's the guy from Deadwood who played
two different roles in Deadwood by the
way dude the Jesse James the role he
played in Jesse James was like he played
such a simpleton but it was there were
so many layers to him I was like this
dude it's [ __ ] crazy and then when I
had heard that you cast him I was like I
had only seen him in those serious I was
like mom Garcia [ __ ] suck the dick on
this boy
[ __ ] the first time he's ever chosen
wrong and it was so spot-on oh because
in your head and I'm sure other people
auditioned for the role in your head can
you tell me who you pictured when you
wrote it I think in my head you know
what I might have pictured Rappaport
because I think I picture Rappaport a
lot yeah he's when I'm writing stuff in
fact there was a time where Rappaport
was going to be Earl but it was way
before
Michael Rapaport every yeah Michael Roth
sorry Michael Rapaport so I might have
pictured Michael Rapaport as as the
father and this because he cracks me up
but yeah Garret came in and just killed
it and I think you know I think Garret
is always the best in anything he does
he's always the best part of it so to me
that combo again when you're just
talking chemistry Hammond Martha
great he just believed them as a couple
so high school what you believed here's
what I loved about it is that there was
something about them you know the
shorthand that people have been together
for a long time have they seem to
automatically have that as a couple yeah
I believed that those two had known each
other for that long and had been in love
and been to the to the point of marriage
where it was like yeah I love you but
I'm I don't you know yeah I don't have
to see you every day do you know I mean
like that was so it felt so real to me
but they had it right away
yeah and they and they got along great
on set always and and I think again when
there's a connection there then that
connection carries over to the screen
and they still hang out they sent me a
picture of the two of them hanging out
actually this past weekend I'm having
dinner with Garrett on Thursday and I
think it's high time the Garrett is the
lead of his own show dude she is so
ridiculously and I was as someone
there's a difference between me
delivering a punchline on stage as a
stand-up and then going to your set and
delivering a punchline but I wasn't
because my instinct as a comic for TV is
to deliver the punchline yeah do you
know I mean yeah to get up there but
what I from watching Jason and Garrett
those guys just said your words I mean
they obviously are good actors yeah but
they didn't deliver the punchline I
think you know I mean yeah but I also
think that like you know when you're on
stage there's that there's a tendency I
mean depending on who you are and what
your act is to lean into a joke yes and
and it's stuff that's very honed and
you've done a bunch of times and you
know it's gonna work and you have that
confidence that lean into it and I tell
a lot of actors sometimes especially
when we're doing stuff on a weekly basis
and I'm so all new stuff I rather them
lean back and do a joke because if it
doesn't land at least you're not falling
on your face yeah you know you said
something man
I don't know if you remember this there
we were there was one look at my
character on Earl died and there was a I
died in a Murphy bed which was a great
way to go it was a great way to go but
there was one episode where I had a lot
of lines and there was some things that
I was just curious I was like I don't
know how to do that I asked you I was
like should I say it like this or say
like this and you said just say the
words and I said no no but when I say to
you you were like just say the words
just say the words it's gonna be fun
yeah
now also I you know and I think
sometimes I say that too because I don't
want to get anybody's in him anybody's
head too much before we do it cuz I'll
always walk over and go and listen hit
this word a little bit more I'm not shy
I'll give a line reading which won't be
a great performance but you'll kind of
get the gist of it and I have some
actors I've worked with that do not like
lying a lot don't why you know I think
it's it's can you explain to people what
a line line reading would be like if I
just come up to you and I do it like if
you're supposed to say you know all
things comedy Ron I go up and go you
know say all things comedy right you
know and I'm doing it for you and then I
want you to mimic me and I think part of
it
look there's ego there that you don't
want to be told how to do the line but I
think more importantly that the actors
that don't like it like Michael Malley
didn't love it and it wasn't a place of
ego at all what he explained to me is
like if you give me a line reading then
it doesn't especially if you do it right
off the bat it doesn't give me time to
interpret it and still put my spin on it
I don't want to just mimic you and so
what would happen with Mike sometimes is
I try to and I'm not the most articulate
guy when it comes to given a note and
that's why I usually fall back on a line
reading so I'll try to explain what I
want and then sometimes that'll work but
if with Mike if I've done explained it
three times he'll just go just do it
just do it really you know at that point
it's like [ __ ] it just do it just do it
and then I'll do it and then and then
then we'll move on but I think you feel
like it was harder because right now you
have like I said you have a certain
amount of cash a so if you walk up to an
actor and say this is the line reading I
want do you think it was harder because
Mike was on yes dear and you were still
kind of oh sure was I think there's
probably more trust now than there was
in the past and maybe there's a little
bit more
I don't mean who knows I mean you could
give someone a line read and you could
feel like they're completely fine with
it they may go home to their family and
go this [ __ ] guy's give me a line
readings and they're pissed off about
yeah I don't know at the end of the day
I just you know say it the right way but
at the same time you never want to do it
in the beginning because like I said
earlier somebody could do it completely
unexpected and it's better than what you
thought so I don't want to start off
telling them how to say it okay you're
writing him on a completely jump you're
writing a musical yeah speaking of mike
omalley yeah yeah that was a weird thing
like Mike called me prob about a year
and a half ago and he called me and he
said hey you want to write a Broadway
musical which is right up your alley and
I go yeah he says listen here's the deal
he goes it's it's all set like the
producers the money's there which is a
hard thing to get you know in Broadway
and the what you might call it the we
have all the music I know how do we have
all the music he says it's Jimmy
Buffett's music we're just doing we're
writing a musical like a jukebox musical
but with all of Jimmy Buffett's music
and he'll write like a couple original
songs so I was like yeah I love Jimmy
Buffett I like working with you and I
guess Buffett was an earl fan and Mike
had worked with him in the past and
that's how it all came together so yeah
we wrote it and we've been working with
a director down in La Jolla and I guess
they're gonna do press about it sometime
but I've mentioned it before anyway so
is that crazy I mean I mean how much
different was that at the end of the day
is it still basically the same process
yeah you're telling a story and you're
trying to make it funny the difference
is like you can't just write any story
you want I mean this the songs we're not
doing like Jersey Boys is a musical it's
about Jersey Boys so they can just go
and then we came up with this song write
and sing the song we're telling an
actual story and trying to shoehorn
Buffett's songs into the story so the
way I did it was I listened to all the
songs I knew they'd want to put in
probably bout 20 25 songs and I started
creating characters based on the songs
then I started to create story turns
that would make sense for those people
to sing those songs in those moments
sometimes we just used the chorus
sometimes we use just a little bit of
verse Jimmy's giving me permission to
kind of change some words now and then
in songs and songs to make topics yeah I
mean not like not like anything to
tomorrow that Margaritaville is like
Thomasville or it's gin and tonic velvet
I think it works you don't want to
change too much because I know that's
gin and juice ville yeah like I went to
see Cat Stevens recently and he was
singing another Saturday night wait as
Cat Stevens what's his name now
Yusuf Islam but I think he was still
billed as Cat Stevens but she sells more
tickets as Cat Stevens
so I went to see him which was great
because I like Cat Stevens but like he's
saying another Saturday night and he
changed the words because like he's
married now and he didn't want to talk
about trying to get laid so he changed
it all about how he's trying to get a
job you know so I'm very conscious if I
don't want to change it too much but you
can't do it it's like going to see
motley crue and if they changed girls
girls girls to like preschool preschool
or even just ladies yeah yeah so so
anyway you know so so we wrote it and
we're doing like this big table read in
December and then you know I've noticed
that things move kind of slow in the
Broadway world but it seems like it's
starting to pick up now and we'll see
what happens with it I don't know okay I
haven't given the number out yet oh [ __ ]
where is this flew by it's already 5:30
all right that's how quickly that
happens so three to three to eight two
seven four to four this is the very
first episode of fairly normal you've
been listening to jazz rolls as Greg
Garcia you call in I apologize if you
have been listening and have not been
calling in the feed isn't working
can't find the show it says channels
offline so what's up okay
deaf person is just not bright now
they're up another up let me see if I
got this mainstream I'm let me see if
there's any questions on here okay man I
don't know some of these questions he
can't answer cuz he still has to work in
this business what are the questions
I'll dance around them
is there any actor or actress that you
would not work with again before you
answer that we have a phone call all
right let's do the phone I know the
answer to that but I don't know if you
can say it
hey this is Josh you're on with Josh and
Greg Garcia what's going on hey guys how
you doing tonight good how are you
what's your name this is Justin hey
what's up Justin hey guys I'm doing well
I'm doing very well man good you got
anything you want to ask Greg yeah yeah
I do I was a huge raising hopes man is
there any opportunity that that you see
in the future to bring that back as a
limited series kind of the way that
x-files is is doing I don't know I mean
you know it's a show that kind of
fizzled out towards the end so the idea
of like getting people real excited
about it to do that would be tough I
mean not unlike an Earl movie it's be
something I jump right back into and and
and have a lot of fun doing certainly
you know with Netflix and stuff they're
doing like fuller house and yeah and so
you know who knows if that takes off you
never know if all of a sudden there's
this market to kind of bring back cast
and do like limited things would be
great I mean I think for any show I mean
I think even like you know I was
laughing the other day even doing like a
yes dear like coming up on it now and
just doing like a really edgy version of
it would be would be funny but but yeah
you never know what is it you liked
about hope so much Justin was it you
liked that you liked the inheritors or
what do you like that no to be honest
with you I mean the very first episode
was so bizarre and how it was set up I
was like how are they going to get a
show out of this and it intrigued me to
come back and and watch the second
episode and the second episode was so
different that it made me fall in love
with these characters plus I really love
Martha Plimpton
how I mean amazed it yeah she's so good
and to be honest with you she is so
political and she's not afraid about it
I think a lot of people in Hollywood are
afraid to put their opinions and their
views out there she is who she is
oh she is not a fifty oh no she is not
afraid not at all
no-no-no I've been reading her Twitter
lately she she's uh she welcomes it she
how comes yeah yeah it was just a
feel-good I mean you watch that show to
feel good about life and I lived in
Illinois so I'm middle America and I
just thought that was the sweet spot for
me well you know I love that you know
thanks interesting in and just in the
hope had it too and so did Earl at the
end of the day there was that last two
sentences of your show that had a moral
and heart yeah yeah we and we wouldn't
do it every week I mean sometimes we'd
have episodes and I'm like we're just
you were jamming this in here just go
out on jokes or whatever but yeah for me
if I can make you laugh somebody told me
once they said your shows are funny but
you know what after I watch them I feel
good and that meant a lot to me and and
and you know if I can have that moment I
like it and I think maybe it was a
little bit completely different shows
but when I came up in the Miller Boyett
camp of Family Matters and all their
shows yeah they would have that what
they would call their violent moment at
the end of the show and it was done a
different way but it was still a
structure where you're laughing or
laughing and then there's a there's a
nice thing you know you can do that
organically and in a way that people
don't think it's cheesy or anything
I think that's worthwhile yeah I agree
hey Justin yeah the nice if everybody
felt that hug right yeah thanks for
calling Justin thank everybody talk to
you soon you know it's funny dude is
that and I also listen I remember
certain things that you say because you
are a successful dude who and I respect
the not only the way that you've gotten
your success the not only have you never
wavered of what you like to do but
you've stayed like a humble good dude
but I remember that
yes dear pilot episode yeah there was at
one scene with the baby in the casino
yeah and you were like this scene is
gonna sell the show yeah the baby
walking on water was that that's the
only thing that the the show tested
mediocre and then at the end this baby
walked on water because of the the thing
they did with the vide
and that's bike through the roof and
that's the only reason the show got on
the air which is crazy because like one
joke got that show on there but it goes
what a great lesson is make people laugh
yeah make people laugh in there that's
gonna be okay the question about is
there one person that you would not yeah
I'm not gonna answer I know you but I'll
tell you this story about yesterday and
the baby walking which is funny we were
in the casino and we were shooting where
the baby walks and we have twins and the
baby won't the baby's supposed to walk
like two steps and fall down well the
baby just learned how to walk and I'm
thinking a little walk and a fall down
but it's walking it's walking as well
it's not falling down it's not falling
down my god she's just more shooting and
shooting and shooting and I'm like what
are we gonna do and I said hey listen uh
what are we tied a little bit of like a
fishing wire to the back of the kids
belt loop and gave it just a little tug
everybody looked at me like I was crazy
but I like I have kids I have kids they
fall in their butts all day long like
big deal so they go now you're crazy you
can't do that and so I said alright
alright and then we kept shooting and
kept shooting cap should I go hold on
I'm gonna talk to a social worker so I
said hey listen could we tie a little he
says I don't know let's talk to the mom
and we talked to mom the mom says yeah
they found their butts all the time
what's the big deal so sure enough we we
tie the kids belt loop to the fishing
wire there there I got the prop guy like
standing off-camera
getting ready to go why the prop guy is
the one that's in charge of tugging the
baby I have no idea the baby gets up and
starts to walk towards the stool we're
not even rolling the guy panics pulls it
the kid goes forward instead of
backwards and cracks his head on the
school start screaming screaming bloody
murder the mom goes in and picks it up
the whole soundstage is just quiet
everybody in the whole place is looking
at me judging me and the kid cries and I
leaned over to Allen Kirschenbaum and I
said alright let's tie the other one up
and give it another which they would not
do so we actually end up just reversed
we we just had the kids sit down and
stand up and then we were
hilarious yeah oh we have it Ellen
that's a great Faithie tide of a baby
it's pretty amazing yeah I get the job
done
hey you're on with Josh and Greg welcome
to fairly normal what's your name where
you calling from my name is Carrie and
I'm calling from Orlando Florida what's
happening Carrie how are you I'm great
how are you guys doing doing very good
you got a question for Greg yeah what
was it like working with Will Arnett on
the Millers wills awesome will you know
I had known will through a friend
actually through mike omalley keep
talking about him and I saw that wills
show was gonna be cancelled it looked at
I read in the trades that that up all
night wasn't looking good so I texted
them and I said will you you know will
you come look at this pilot and I'd
always liked will and been a fan and he
was great I mean you know it was we both
hadn't done multicam in a while and that
show was you know kind of you know right
out of the gate was was was pretty good
successful you know in the ratings and
then they moved it around and and then
we kind of got unexpectedly cancelled
too but working with Will was fantastic
and he was one of the things we'll said
to me that was so funny as we got
canceled like on a Friday and they said
that you know we could shoot the last
episode if we wanted to and so I talked
to will and I said you know what do you
think the crew gets paid and he's like
yeah let's just do it let's just have
fun you know so there we are Monday and
we're after the weekend and everybody
had written about the show being
canceled and he goes you know all
weekend long all I read was like Will
Arnett show killer Will Arnett show
killer it's like you know obviously
after my first show got canceled they
didn't write that but as soon as the
second one got canceled they wrote will
on that show a show killer and when the
third one got cancelled they wrote we
learn that show killer and the fourth
show got canceled you know there's other
components here there's other actors
there's writing you know there's all
kinds of things there's time slots he
goes but I got to tell you would this
one finally they might be honest and so
I you know I just loved that about will
because he doesn't take himself too
seriously he's absolutely hilarious he's
a pro on set I loved him
absolutely love the experience well see
it with what did you ever let him go is
he a good improv guy yeah he wouldn't so
much improv as much as like he would
come over and pitch jokes and we do him
you know he wouldn't like just on the
fly just start saying things he'd always
come check with me first or not even
check with me as much as just like pitch
or he might have like half he might be
halfway there with a new joke and then
we'll talk through it together and come
up with something we both like and so it
was very collaborative and he'd come up
to my office and talk about certain
scenes and we'd talked through it
together so yeah he's a funny guy he's a
good writer so yeah are you more open to
that process like a collaborative rather
than somebody improvising are you more
open to somebody coming before the scene
and going I want to try rather do that
because then we can just get on the same
page because sometimes people think
something's funny and it is but it might
undermine their character it might hurt
the story in a certain way you know just
because sometimes you can get a laugh
but it kind of takes takes over the
scene or makes it seem weird you know so
I'd like to be to be able to talk to
them about that
awesome any other questions for Greg uh
no that was it but uh Josh yeah big fan
of yours been listening to you since
Josh and Ross I think you want to say
keep up the good work man you are funny
as [ __ ] I appreciate it man thank you
for calling in absolutely have a great
night guys all right bye take care what
and I know because we both have street
parking we don't I get towed oh yeah
that's right what that's big thing at
the all things comedy hotel that's how
big a star as we are what is there
anything that you haven't done that was
another question that I got a bunch of
times online anything you haven't done
that you want to do you know you and I
yeah couple years ago you and I went out
to dinner and we brought our wives and
you you asked my wife who writes scripts
movie scripts a bunch of questions just
about that process yeah is that
something because that you that is that
something you want to do or you use I
mean I'd love to do a movie someday I
mean I've been so spoiled in the sense
that when you're a writer of TV and you
create shows you get the final say on
everything and so I've directed a bunch
of single camera
and so I think ultimately if I ever did
write a movie I'd like to also direct it
because I'd like to see it all the way
through right if somebody would let me
do that I haven't really gotten around
to trying it because I've usually been
working in TV so I haven't had time so
ultimately that wouldn't that would be
something I wouldn't mind checking off
at some point also there's a book that
of short stories that I've been working
through a long time that that the UC is
not the one you sent to me yeah
that is so [ __ ] funny yeah it's just
kind of twisted stories he said oh can
you tell people kind of what it is yeah
I don't care I mean what's somebody
gonna rip it off great if they do a good
job I'll read it and enjoy it's just
that I used to go to a guest house like
rental like vacation houses to write
just to get away and be in a quiet spot
and kind of force myself to get
something done and sometimes I get
writer's block so it they would have
like a guest book there that people
would sign and go we had a great time by
the way the dishwasher is not working
and whatever and I would write like a
long fucked-up bizarre story of
something weird that happened in the
house so can you give a brief example
well like one time like this older
couple rented the house and had their
family up and their son was their son's
fiancee was an atheist and they were
very religious so they drugged the woman
in the middle of the night and baptized
her in the hot tub stuff like that like
all that meth heads that meth heads that
broke into the house just so you know
this is things that you're leaving do I
leave them yes I write it all and leave
it for the next people to read yeah like
I had like people get in fights and
stick a fork in someone's eye so I a
picture like the next people are Reena
gonna define some of the stories are so
[ __ ] funny yeah they're fun and
they're just and it was also just a fun
way to just write stuff that I can't put
on network TV that's just bizarre so
I've made a collection of those I've
even like I've tried to even sell it as
a TV show like an anthology TV show but
I haven't had much luck with that but so
I'd love to publish that at some point
cuz that was a that was fun too right
yeah you know I just know if you know
this I'm a New York Times I know
best-selling yeah I know you're gonna
have to give me some tips well I mean I
would love to tip number one
smoked a bunch of wheat okay okay all
right that's it that's all I got that's
my tip number one the same is pretty
easy I actually you know somebody asked
me this week and I was on this
interesting as a comic man do you know
sometimes sometimes I come back from
weekends it's it's hard sometimes not
the bird like this weekend was not a
ticket wise yeah was my worst in eight
years okay so it's like you cook you
come home kind of licking your wounds
yeah wondering it's really hard to
[ __ ] it's tough when you get knocked
down and get back up yes but here's my
look you always see even though you seem
to get up and end up on TV but like one
of the most important like in this
business in general is that word no or
all that [ __ ] doesn't seem to and maybe
it doesn't you handle it well but
doesn't seem to affect you well it
affects me I try to make it affect me in
a positive way I've never done anything
that's been any good that I wasn't angry
at somebody for turning something down
and I used that anger to fuel me to do
the next thing like yes dear I think
stayed on the air for six years because
the critic [ __ ] all over it and I'd wake
up every morning and go yeah you know
what you're gonna [ __ ] watch it for
six years you [ __ ] then I've
created my name is Earl and I pitched it
all over town and everybody said it's
not a TV show sorry we're not gonna do
it and I just hung on to it I battled I
battled I finally got it on then it got
cancelled I was mad about that so I ran
over to Fox and pitched raising hope
because I wanted to get that going so
you know III said something to my son
who plays hockey he didn't make a couple
years ago he didn't make the a team he
made the B team and they have these
tryouts all weekend long where Friday
night you try out and then they tell you
if you made the team and they'd Friday
night he tried out he didn't make the
team Saturday night he tried out and
they told me he didn't make the team yet
and then Saturday tries out again and
they told them specifically you're on
the B team you didn't make the a team so
now you have Sunday worth the tryouts
which really doesn't mean anything you
just go there and skate and we're
driving and he was bummed out and we
were driving and I said you're gonna
skate hard today I hope you're going
heart today and really kick ass out
there and he said why would I do that it
doesn't matter anymore they told me last
night I wasn't on the team and I said
because today is the first day you start
showing them they were wrong yeah
and he got this like spark in his eye
and he was like yeah I get that too
let me tell you something it's one of
the things that I tell my kids but it's
one of the things that I came home from
this weekend with I have never wanted to
do a podcast more than I did wanted to
come in here today I've never liked I
wrote all yesterday like that knocked
down yeah there's only you can do one of
two things you can lay down there yeah
or you can get up and go oh yeah [ __ ]
you I just wrote a script
I loved it man I wrote this script I
thought there was gonna be a bidding war
all over town in the cable and streaming
space I loved it man I sent it out
everywhere and just [ __ ] the bed nobody
wanted to do it it's just it got passed
everywhere and I found out like the last
couple knows last week and I was like
man and then this weekend I just spent
all weekend coming up with a new show
and I love it and I'm gonna go pitch it
you know in the next week and and that
was all because I was like well what am
I gonna do I gotta do something did you
know that whenever I go to when I go to
the gym and this is a very disturbing
fact about me okay when I go to the gym
when I go to the gym yeah I pick one
person a day to hate okay and I just
hate their face and I hate the [ __ ]
shirt they're wearing and I workout
angry yeah because of that like it's the
same thing like I yeah like writing
angry working out angry yeah but with
that every now and then like somebody
will glance over to me I've had a guy
say to me hey man do I know you because
I'm looking at him like I wanna [ __ ] on
his face he's like do I know you I'm
like I'm sorry I picked you out to hate
today yeah like sorry I'm sorry will you
pick me up to what I'm like no offense
no if I can pick somebody else well I
kind of told him I got out angry and I
put some angry music on and then I look
at your [ __ ] stupid face
and he's like
okay yeah well you look great yeah thank
you I don't know if you're fishing for a
compliment but you look fantastic you la
anger can be a very good thing if you
use it properly all right Greg Garcia we
don't want to get towed all right it's
5:45 let me just say this it I'm so I'm
listen it speaks volumes that and I know
where you live
it speaks volumes I'm just the [ __ ]
person you are that you're here in
Hollywood you know you're gonna have to
drive back in that [ __ ] truck no I
don't like leaving my home I know it's
speaks volumes to it and here's what I
will say the last thing and I know you
you're not a big fan of compliments or
anything but hey what the other last
thing that your success has shown me is
that you can be a good guy who treats
people well and still get to do what you
want to do and be successful at it
like there are like I think that's true
I think that's true and I'll tell you
this I'll tell you to address that point
I'm very proud of something that
happened but it also shows you why I
don't I can't get a big head I met a
very nice guy who created the show
blackish not long ago at a Dodgers game
and I went up to the CA suite where he
was and I met him and he was very nice
and we had a nice chat and what he said
to me he gave me the obligatory like I
like your shows and stuff like that but
then he said you know I've never heard
anybody say a bad story about you which
I think for the time amount you've been
in the business and trust me I'm sure
there's people like they you can find
him but but but I said I said wow that's
that's very cool that means a lot to me
because that really is more important to
me at the end of the day than the shows
and stuff that that you know that
because the whole reason I got into
comedy is I want people to like me you
know right so that's very important to
me so that was really cool then I went
home and my wife was half asleep in bed
and I told her that story and I said
yeah and then he said that he'd never
met anybody that had can say a bad thing
about me and she immediately said have
him call me
so yeah they could call ambien Greg he's
a good time and being great
he's a good time he hasn't been around
and claimed no I used to get texts from
ambien Greg o ambien Greg would eBay
shop he would write emails to the
network dude I would get a text from
ambien Greg and then the next day I
would get a text from you that said did
you get a text from him being Greg glass
I know my client did yeah
ambien Greg was one time naked in his
driveway with Lucas Neff the star of
raising Hope on the phone and he claimed
that he was taking Lucas Neff through
the neighborhood to go meet Ozzy
Osbourne mmm ambien Greg was a good time
he was a good time yeah he had but it
was time for a me and Greg to hit the
shelf he had to go wait can you tell me
the weirdest thing ambien Greg bought
online oh gosh I don't know probably
just I mean no I was pretty solid with
my investments online I you know it's
like you know old lunch boxes of TV
shows and stuff you know pretty solid
stuff Smokey and the Bandit car yeah
smokey the Bandit car I think about a
pacer once you did buy a pace yeah the
problem with ambien Greg is I would I
would somehow like my wife was so
frustrated with ambien Greg and I would
sometimes be doing stuff like crazy to
like like I was doing a bit but the
things were so crazy that it wasn't
really a bit because I was yeah like I
was getting to my car naked at one point
and and the neighbors had some guests
over and they were leaving and they
looked over and she's just yelling at me
and yeah
ambi and Greg had to go but he was a
good time and me and Greg was good good
stuff yeah um guy hey maybe I'll do this
again an ambien Greg will do it listen
I'm gonna tell you something right now
I would love a me and Greg can come in
and he'll talk to mushroom Josh and let
me do I promise you this the day I leave
Hollywood to retire and all my stuff is
packed up in the car the next of last
stop I make will be a me Greg will do an
interview and then I'm on the road can't
okay wait neither guys thank you for
listening to the first episode a fairly
normal and thank you Greg Garcia man
thank you very much and we will see you
it guys every we're into this every more
they it'll be online every Tuesday and
then once a week I will drop a solo
podcast that I will be doing from my
hotel room that will be hi Josh
hi Josh does solo solo hotel room
podcasts the one from this weekend is
really bizarre thank you for listening
love you